all right today my favorite subject came
up again at the Cova 19 briefing with it
you know are there treatments out there
that are already in use with minimal
side effects that could bring relief to
our people in our economy
well our own John Roberts Press dr.
Anthony Fauci about the drug we first
introduced to the wider public on Monday
dr. Joshi was explained yesterday there
has been some promise with
hydroxychloroquine this potential
therapy for people who are infected with
corona virus is there any evidence to
suggest that as with malaria it might be
used as a prophylaxis against Cobra
Manson the answer is is no and and the
the evidence that you're talking about
John is anecdotal evidence so as the
Commissioner of FDA and the president
mentioned yesterday we're trying to
strike a balance between making
something with a potential of an ant of
an effect to the American people
available at the same time that we do it
under the auspices of a protocol that
would give us information to determine
if it's truly safe and truly effective
but the information that you're
referring to specifically is anecdotal
it was not done in a controlled clinical
trial so you really can't make any
definitive statement about it well first
I have great respect for dr. Fauci his
sacrifice for the country but when you
hear something is just anecdotal again
aside from the clinical terminology to
most people and we're talking to most
people in these press conferences it
just doesn't sound too hopeful or too
impressive an anecdotal doesn't really
describe the findings of the world's top
researchers who just a few days ago
published results of their first study
on hydroxychloroquine and
hydroxychloroquine with as if through
Meissen a lot of you probably have taken
Z packs over the years well check out
their findings this is in the long study
despite its small sample size our survey
shows that hydroxychloroquine treatment
is significantly associated the word
significantly there with viral load
reduction or disappearance in kovat 19
patients and its effect is reinforced by
as if through Meissen now look at this
chart that accompanied the report
the blue line is the control group okay
say they took nothing so bad for them
they all have the virus even after six
days the red represents those who
received hydroxychloroquine so some
improvement
so only what is that 40% or so still had
the virus but look at the yellow line
now the yellow line represents the
patients at the end of day five only who
were on a protocol that included
hydroxychloroquine and as if through
Meissen now the researchers in this
study and they're all incredibly
prominent epidemiologists and
researchers dozens and dozens they
understood when they undertook this
project they were tasked by the French
government to do this they understood
the severity of the global crisis were
all facing and they also understood the
risk to millions millions of people
around the world including our health
care workers and they concluded as a
result of all of this thinking and what
they looked at the following we
therefore recommend that kovin 19
patients be treated with
hydroxychloroquine and as if through
Meissen to cure their infection and to
limit the transmission of the virus to
other people in order to curb the spread
of kovat 19 in the world now I
understand that we want our own data
that is a large controlled study we I
understand that's necessary and the
Trump administration is a hundred
percent correct at the same time and
recognizing the benefits already
reported in the use of this drug and the
drug combo that we just mentioned now by
the way hydroxychloroquine a lot of
people don't understand this but it does
not need to be approved by the FDA in
order to be administered by doctors for
off-label use because as I said before
we'd have to go over it but it's four
screw for prescribed for anti malarial
use and also for lupus in some cases our
physicians are already using it in our
major hospitals for kovat patients they
also used it successfully in some cases
against SARS which had a higher
mortality rate the president
as usual has sharp instincts he sees
things that sometimes the intellectuals
and the academics they might get lost in
some of the details but he has sharp
instincts about things and he's pushing
to get millions of doses now into the
United States but I'm a big fan and
we'll see what happens and we all
understand what the doctor said is 100%
correct it's early but we've you know
I've seen things that are impressive and
we'll see if it's very effective it's a
strong it's a strong drug I can also
report tonight that another drug is also
showing significant promise in the fight
against Kovan 19 it's called
act Emre it's an IL six or an anti Lucan
six it's an anti-inflammatory prescribed
mostly for rheumatoid arthritis again an
off-label use is being implemented now
by the Chinese who are finding that it
works very well against kovin 19
pharmaceutical giants Roche and Sanofi
make different versions of this drug our
doctors and our hospitals need all the
ammo they can get to fight this disease
we want fewer people to need ventilators
right we need to reduce that that
absolute necessity to have vents in our
ICUs
because we have a critical shortage we
need to get people home to quarantine if
they're sick then we need after a
necessary amount of time we need to get
those people healthy and back to work as
soon as they're medically cleared again
I respect all the professionals who are
working on this and they're working
ridiculous hours and I respect dr. Fauci
an enormous amount I realize in an ideal
world we want everything buttoned up and
it's perfect as far as randomized trials
go but our country needs solutions and
hope now an old bureaucracies have to
give way to fast action the president
understands this we can't stay in our
homes forever America wants to get back
to work and that's the angle